face à ce coup là on voit la dengue et
des emballements jusqu'à mais la foule à
elle seule à quoi la porter à la gare de
paris gir au ca batna faisait face à la
bonne heure dans la foulée ahmarani
salama sommes les amis doivent être
ménéac liste c'est ça le manque à gagner
donc les combles les aigus son tour mais
on ne prêche pas partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'église utiliser tous les moyens à sa
disponibilité pour propager les
franchises les prêtres qui sait utiliser
les réseaux sociaux
il ouvre un chemin des plus sur le plan
pastoral
[Musique]
un peu comme à manger se délient petit
rejeté lundi la mesure où seuls ou en
couples les auditeurs cherche un peu de
réconfort cherche une parole une parole
qui peuvent leur toucher dans cette
pandémie pour qu'il vive l'espérance
alors cette parole nous nous leur
adressons à travers les messes à travers
les émissions